easy brandon you getting a little toothy
down there sorry
[Applause]
[Applause]
i would never find any person in this
room
except the car oh no
except for carl where's the man he's old
he's useless
he's just not good to me
so carl sorry girl you gotta go
for real you gotta got them
sometimes we get so caught up in loving
our own family we forget about
loving
loving everyone
loving everyone in the world right okay
and that's important totally important
alan is a himalayan and you can find
himalayan on the couch
[Laughter]
you should do stand up
now wait a cotton pick a minute uncle
ben
[Applause]
if you're looking for a place to relax
with an old lady look no further new
york's hottest club is spicy
opened in 2017
on the upper east side of a dumpster
[Applause]
where did you go to school the
everglades i'm sorry time
for every new thing you teach us
you open the world to us like a stubborn
coconut
you're just a loser who could never
afford to eat at terezano so you made it
your pathetic life's little mission to
destroy the people who can
media is so sensitive they're so
secretive
they may never know how many people
perished
oh stop yelling at me i can't be yelled
at my dad was a really messed up guy he
was really messed up and he would never
do this to me not in terrizano's
i know baby
if this weren't terrazzano's
i would beat you to death
[Applause]
you know what
you should be ashamed of yourselves
i think you should get home that given
there's nothing going on stewart a
secret who
get back on san vicente take it to the
tent
then switch over to the 405 north and
let it dump you out into mulholland
where you belong
let's start with marconius wow what did
you do with him
uh he said already
[Music]
and did you feel threatened miss
rafferty
no no no no no no
look it wasn't my worst wednesday night
and how did the aliens return you all to
earth
oh i was carried down
gently
okay uh
i'm here no no no now what do i do
look at him angrily and say
what are you doing
no come on
hurt
[Music]
[Applause]
that'll be five thousand dollars good
day to you both
what the hell was
that we misplaced your baby
by the way it's official
[Applause]
i can't have children
sure
at this time of day it's going to be
jammed
are you crazy
just get out of the chitty get out of
here
[Applause]
what is a human kite it's that thing
where you tie a string to a [ __ ] and a
windbreaker
and then run through a field
[Laughter]
[Music]
seriously america
look at pete davidson's lips
[Applause]
i'm going to put roses
something that you bring to a party
why do i gotta bring something you
invited me that's a stupid ass question
and i hope you burn in hell
this place has everything
asbestos lupus
the magazines at supercuts
dan cortes
[Applause]
there you go
okay is there any more food
i need to get something done my throat
to fight what is coming up
[Applause]
you're gonna be doing a lot of doobie
rolling
when you're living in a van down by the
river
each chicken looks as good as this one
that's a chicken man guaranteed
if your mom likes dracon you might like
chicken
dave
dave
dave
david
have you heard of blacula the black
dracula yes
well they have a jewish dracula oh
what's his name sydney applebaum
[Applause]
do you know one thing that bugs me
[Applause]
i'm sorry
spencer
i'm gonna show the campbell's what
you've been working on oh you see it's a
dance
easy
easy
[Applause]
what is a human suitcase it's a thing of
when a [ __ ] on roller skates
wears all of your clothes and then you
pull them through an airport
step five
step on
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
everybody uses math
[Music]
lisa simpson
bill cosby
mario party
tiny dick
and morgan mindy
no no no sorry